j'appelle à réagir et à d'autres bonsoir
isabella et asie relève d'albon soir
[Musique]
je préfère l'amour quelque part où
isabelle mon mari m'a ainsi sur un
poteau mais s'est accrochée aux barbelés
des meilleures pratiques j'avais le dos
aux barbelés j'ai gardé les dix ans en
pleine rue qui avait pas de géant
barbelés dans le soutien arrive avec une
serviette de plage façon tahitienne
autour de la taille car j'étais à
bordeaux au bord de l'eau je trouve que
nous y je bronze la serviette comme ça
et j'avance dans l'eau comme ça je suis
très gêné sienne j'ai combien de doigts
à la question si la route tonique
lapacca plateau la question se pose pas
c'est vrai que ça voilà on n'avait pas
honte des saints c'est pareil ça peut
être que boney m
voilà oui et tu passe après alors oui
qui est gagnant ou chercher
[Musique]
dépôt parce qu'arriver mais vous et
c'est vrai que tu as un béni non mais
ses chansons mais alors en revanche le
look le physique et les rats me semble
t'il oreilles ça fait longtemps que j'ai
remarqué
moi je suis venue spontanément comme ça
parce que vous êtes mon bachelor d' on
dirait la mère de big flo et oli
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de ça
ça nous a d'abord je déteste ça alors
oui je suis allé au procès de classes a
b c plus de 120 chroniqueurs qui nous
intéresse 881 dépression
est-ce que la survie l'année prochaine
dépendent du résultat du bac je vous
dire la survie de dépens et donc je vais
vous dire les gens vous adore 1 dans la
série
alors on va démarrer par vous emballez
jimenez a très bien alors mais il accuse
un élément absolument indispensable de
tpm paix tu fais partie de l'adn de
cette émission tu as de l'accord c'est
pas les pavés là même qui décide avec la
culture tu as une bonne dose de second
degré et dieu sait s'il en faut dans
cette émission vraiment les anecdotes
qu'on qualifie de folle
oui en veux tu en voilà qui parfois nous
laisse coi les uns et les autres mais on
en raffole
et puis ton duo avec gilles moi je m'en
lasse pas ça fait neuf ans que ce duo là
me fait rire même si je suis souvent en
désaccord avec gilles mais votre duo me
fait marrer en revanche comme tu dirais
voilà tu prends la parole même quand ton
talent dont elle n'est pas à toi c'est à
dire que tu parles sur les camarades sur
les petits camarades
tu marmonne tout au long de l'émission
et on entendait à leur place juste son
dentier ça
enfin tu dragues tout ce qui bouge mais
qui est invité à se faire plaisir une
drague mais quand j'ai vu qu'il mettrait
sur bois cas là elle était sur le my
book à la dia et peut-être mon délire
excellent son mari je veille au grain
mais attention voilà autrement à kayes
son mariage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la moa callas la vache milka maïza et
évidemment pour nous avoir tous
supporter pendant neuf ans je te donne
l'excellente note de six polonais alors
moi même où je suis fan de ton
personnage je suis fan de ton marmots
nage je suis fan de tabarka
tarifs 6 et toujours de bonne humeur
contrairement à certains toi tu es
vraiment toujours toujours avec le style
et en plus que ce qu'on ne sait pas est
ce qu'on dit pas assez c'est que tu es à
l'écouté et tu es de legends of tu
gardes le chat des gens tu donnes de
l'argent mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette aide éclaté rosso dimanche donc
pour ça franchement moi je suis fan de
toi de ton personnage et je t'aime donc
je te mets un 10 sur 10 ans
[Applaudissements]
gérard l'attrait disait je vais te dire
ils testeront tombé au premier accroc
quand même ça m'empêche pas de lui mais
oui je sais c'est pas cher et c'est vrai
qu'elle est beaucoup de gens sans rien
révéler rezé très bien la garder alors
d'abord isa je trouve que tu excelles
dans l'autodérision et c'est pas facile
parce que c'est là que tu te prends scud
sur scud sur par exemple sur ton âge et
tout ça est rude en reprend ce alors
même pas si elle était vraiment ça l'est
vraiment 102 ans où la valve n'avait pas
parlé très chaude oui mais elle a quand
même beaucoup d'autodérision et rit
beaucoup
c'est très agréable tout autour de la
table c'est une bonne humeur ensuite je
trouve je trouve que tu es joueur quand
on entend pas généralement quelque chose
on rit pour du chanteur une fille c'est
tout tu dois tout il connaît tout
parfois tu oublie un peu mais c'est pas
gênant ensuite j'adore tes anecdote un
peu désuète j'aime bien tes blagues un
peu vintage je trouve que ça fait partie
de ton adn après ce que j'aime pas aussi
un peu comme valérie c'était borborygmes
était onomatopées quand on parle on a
toujours un petit cadeau d'un petit un
petit écho a rien qui va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m ainsi ce hommage à m6 ou un oeuf
hommage à w9 et finalement j'ai fait la
moyenne et je t'aime bien cet ennemi
[Applaudissements]
rotman d'après la moyenne entre 6 et 1
tf1 donc aller guillaume genton voyez
2010 le vrai dans ce que j'ai pensé
démission ça fait huit ans que là pour
moi était indispensable on puisse être
vraie crédibilité de journalistes et
journalisme à dire que c'est très
important
thaddée très bonne analyse le seul truc
pour moi c'est pas mal ça c'est vrai
c'est que tu as beaucoup de second de me
refaire briller ce week-end ouais c'est
vrai les revendeurs qui ma course et sur
toi même topo pour moi c'est une vraie
preuve d'intelligence le seul bémol mois
contrairement aux autres je trouve que
tu ne parles pas assez dans l'émission
faut que tu as passé sur les sujets
j'aimerais bien entendre son avis bas et
même en même temps tu vois tu sais pas
ce qu'on lui donne
on lui donne mais mais quoi
malheureusement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
castaldi oui chef
c'est vrai que c'est un pis des
démissions l'adorent mais c'est vrai que
le brouhaha permanent que c'est que tout
le temps c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
c'est un peu fatigant et moi j'ai un
vrai problème c'est que dès qu'on parle
de m6 jamais je ne t'ai vu petit à petit
il s'arrête m6 était paraît il a fumé
une écrite ou net
une petite grille 1 tout s'est toujours
bien toujours parfait même quand ça ça
s'est planté tu expliques que si on
prend tels chiffres ça a marché et ça
c'est vrai que ça veut dire qu'elle nous
défendra aussi c'est vrai que voilà donc
ce n'est qu'elle est fidèle et c'est
vrai que l'acteur c'est pour ça qu'on
aime qu'on les aime mais c'est vrai que
moi c'est vrai que j'aurais aimé un jour
te voir défoncé m6
mais ça n'arrivera jamais je crois en
tout les cas peut-être un jour mais sur
une solution
d'ailleurs c'est quoi obliger les femmes
à 6 voilà voilà les shérifs et je vais
pas faire tout le monde puisse choisir
encore bien sûr deux super nes n'ont pas
fait dire je précise pour être maître
qu'isabelle est une amie
énorme point positif c'est que c'est une
amie qui lève tout le temps la main pour
parler bien sûr et plus elles lèvent la
main
vous voulez donner la parole j'ai essayé
de comprendre pourquoi et le problème
isabelle sais que tu penses que chaque
fois que tu vas dire quelque chose c'est
intéressant même jamais moi je vais te
donner un conseil d'ami
ça fait neuf ans que tu es là sans rien
dire c'est trop tard mais c'est y pas de
changer toi de rire de temps en temps et
ça ira très bien
c'est un peu sévère mais pour la dodge
était équilibré et avec vos équipes
on a repris toutes les interventions
d'isabelle toutes les interventions
depuis le début de la saison
tout ce qui était pertinent et j'en ai
trouvé d'où les fautes label très flou
ça mérite bien un merveilleux deux camps
[Musique]
j'ai merdé comme ça même si je pense
c'est celui qu'il aime le plus
moi j'adore je me souviens comprendre 35
samedi
non mais ça on le sait c'est notre mamie
nous à nous elle est là depuis longtemps
moi je la regardais déjà quand j'étais
téléspectateurs et j'adore ça ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adorais fait partie de ceux qui
bossent le plus l'émission away revel
travail avant l'édition mais souffre
elle est où le temps doit être aussi
donne pas souvent la parole ou pas pas
comme vous voudrez jeu comme benjamin je
trouve que parfois pas ses objectifs sur
les programmes de m6 alors fois tu
défends trop m6 et le groupe airtel donc
c'est tout à son honneur mais je trouve
que cette année avec le co vide le
manque de public de manque de happening
le manque de jeu dans tpm paix tu coûtes
a été beaucoup en recul et je trouve
qu'on t'a beaucoup moins entendu et moi
quand je n'étais pas là pendant les deux
mois où je me suis reposé je regardais
et je tentais pas beaucoup donc je
trouve que pour moi personnellement et
c'est pas méchant parce que vous êtes en
train de vous dire c'est que l'année
prochaine tu vas beaucoup tenait de la
flotte
voilà ce que je pense - barca et je
pense que déjà appelé aussi mais c'est
pas de sa faute j'ai pas dit que c'est
sa faute est égal à payer le contexte et
du coup bah je me suis je me suis dit en
fait s'cusez moi conseils de classe mais
que leur saison
celle là je pense que maintenant il a
mal on verra
allez voter invaincu
bon alors j'ai fait un petit compliment
quand on perd c'est un petit complément
comme on fait son prof
alors on s'est croisé à nos débuts en
outre 44 tu sais tu venais d'être tondus
à la libération
mais moi je juge pas tu sais faire du
cinéma c'est vraiment de la merde tu es
entré dans mon coeur sans y être invité
mois le solitaire en durcit mais au fond
de moi c'est toi que j'attendais même si
tu prends des connards même si tu mange
avec les doigts
nos rendez-vous sont des parenthèses
enchantées c'est jean luc lahaye et sud
jean luc lahaye et amélie tu réalises
notre émission le savap atteint vite
chez moi sans en être
spriet mais tout au fond de moi c'est
toi que j'attendais
[Applaudissements]
il accueille sur dix doigts seconde est
d'oublier mais nous on se serre c'est un
joueur rare est fan je pense pas papa
chanteur espèce domino sortait le
sa mère a l'air
[Applaudissements]
isabelle on va voir les notes 10 à 12
regardez ma note de quoi est il la mine
est incomplet de la moyenne des tweets
5,35 de moyenne générale pour isabelle
c'est pas mal du tout comme ça mais on
est obligé de commencer par exemple ce
serait un petit peu c'est l'axé là bas
c'est la patronne
[Applaudissements]